defecation demilitarization in the sense
that there are no threats to our
security military threats to the territory of
Ukraine and
this task remains
now when you know when there
was a meeting of negotiators in Istanbul there was
one geography and
our willingness to accept the Ukrainian
proposal was based on that geography on the
geography of the end of March
2022 is the
general one,
so if the battles of pain, because now the
geography is different,
it is far from only the DPR and LPR, it is also the
Kherson region of the Zaporozhye region and a
number of other territories, and this process
continues as the west is such a zemstvo
in impotent rage that they poured desire into desire
as much as possible
to aggravate the situation, they are
pumping Ukraine with more and more
long-range weapons of these oh Mars, like
the same butchers or someone they
boast that they have already received 300 km of
ammunition, which means that the
geographical task will be moved away from the
current line even further because we
cannot allow that on
that part  Ukraine which  th will
control
Zelensky there or who will replace him
there was a weapon that
will pose a direct threat to
our territory and the territory of those
republics that have declared their
independence and those who want to
determine their future on their own